Hey so as you see here this is joint
work Nick Rider
and this will fit pretty nicely in right
after mohan stock where he gives this
sort of conjecture that would have been
really nice if we had had it that's
false and you could kind of see that the
content of this talk and and this is
basically me sort of talking about the
content of a particular paper me and
Nick wrote you can basically see it as
what we were able to get along the way
to trying to formulate and prove that
conjecture that ends up being false so
let me just get started having said that
so I'm gonna kind of briefly go through
these these couple of examples that you
probably either seen either earlier
today or you know at the bootcamp or
some other time
and there's even other examples that
were talked about today that I'm I'm not
going to talk about but they're all they
all kind of fit in the same category
which you'll see here
so in trying to solve this cat and
singer problem
Marcus Spielman is through the sava
looked at this mixed characteristic
polynomial right where you have some
characteristic polynomial with some
extra variables with a bunch of matrices
you apply some differential operator you
plug in a bunch of variables to be 0
there's other formulations of this but
you care about exactly some kind of root
bound about this okay you want to know
how much how big the largest fruit can
be and as I mentioned this this is sort
of the main technical object of study if
you can get some kind of root bound on
this right which is that's the question
if you can get a root bound you can use
this interlacing families argument to
get some root bound for some particular
elements of some sum so I haven't
written it like this but you could see
this as the expected characteristic
polynomial of sums of independent rank
one PSD matrices and you want to make
some claim about some particular one
right so this is this standard existence
proof that interlacing families is used
for so you've bound the roots of this
you get roots of something you care
about and that's that's what you want to
do very similarly in this argument about
Rama news and graphs there's some
polynomial like this some very
similar yeah I didn't write it quite
like like the other one but all on the
next slide you'll see it's just some
differential operator applied to some
determinants and you similarly care
about you know bounding the max word
you have some side adjacency matrices
you look at their characteristic
polynomials and you and you kind of play
the same game okay you want to know that
you wanna be able to bound the roots and
if you can which they're able to do then
you can get some similar bound for some
particular element in this interlacing
yeah okay but this I'm kind of just
watching over this very quickly this is
stuff that's been talked about before
the point is right in both of these
situations you can write this polynomial
you care about is some determinant with
some differential operator applied to it
and then you set some variables to be
zero and you want to bound the roots of
this same with this second situation it
turns out this is an equivalent
formulation and like I said this is what
you want to do you have some constant
coefficient differential operators apply
to some polynomials and you want to know
how the roots move so what this talk
then is going to be about is it's going
to kind of move away from these specific
applications and it's going to ask how
can we solve this question in general
for particular classes of polynomials in
particular we're gonna be looking at
real stable polynomials and the idea we
had or the hope was that we could
somehow generalize this barrier method
to some big theory kind of like
emulating maybe the bourgeois brundin
characterization with some kind of like
stronger form that gives you root bounds
or something like this right that was
our goal and like I said that this sort
of at the end the big conjecture ended
up being false but along the way there
are some pretty interesting things that
we that we figured out
so in order to do this we're going to
define this object with Mohan already
defined I might use a slightly different
normalization and I certainly am using a
different way to write it than he wrote
it he wrote it as some expected
characteristic polynomial of some
matrices it turns out an equivalent
formulation is this and what I'm gonna
what what I'm using here is that this
partial X so the K is just going to be
the derivative spec two XK times and the
point is somehow you you are taking like
D derivatives and you're putting K of
them on P and maybe D KP minus K of them
on Q
this one you happen to be plugging in
zero that one you're plugging in X so it
ends up being this you know it still
ends up being a univariate polynomial of
the same degree as the original ones and
this is gonna be the main operator we're
gonna look at so this is called the
finite free convolution or the additive
convolution so before I'll say why it's
called that but before I say that I just
want to point out that if you think
about this any constant coefficient
differential operator on polynomials at
most degree D can be written somehow
like this at some convolution by a
particular polynomial okay so what you
can do is if you have your coefficients
next to the next to the derivatives you
just make those coefficients be the
coefficients of Q maybe with some you
know factorials or something like this
okay and this ends up then right
whenever you sort of just work this out
this is like the D minus K the
coefficient of Q of the factor times the
Kait derivative of P so somehow this
this encapsulates all possible constant
coefficient differential operators okay
so why is it called the fronted free
convolution it turns out to be some
finite dimensional approximation to the
free convolution free probability theory
I will be honest with you by the extent
of my intuition about that fact is is
limited but MSS Marcus feel Ministry of
Sabah kind of talked about this in in
one of their papers and in particular
atom Marcus has like a pretty extensive
paper about the connections and and what
sort of things happen when you limit
what you can say things like this the
thing I'll focus on more which I am much
more familiar with is why it's called
the additive convolution
and I mean there's a more general
question here why why you know why do
this right what's the point this seems
to just make things very confusing okay
you've taken something that like it's
maybe pretty straight forward some
differential operator you've put it in
this weird form okay the main reason why
you want to do this is well there are a
couple reasons this is maybe the first
one so let's suppose we forget about
real coefficients in real rootedness and
we just have some complex univariate
polynomials and we know that their roots
lie in some circles some discs or like a
circular region so it could be a half
plane or an exterior of a disc as well
could use for that you could use for
these well if you know where those are
and you take the additive convolution
then you know that the roots of the
convolution are contained in the
Minkowski sum of these two discs so this
is a pretty like surprising fact it's
not obvious why this should be the case
and there's probably the best proof of
this that I know is using some kind of
symbol of polynomials argument which I
won't go into but you can do something
like that the the the symbol of things
related to this out of convolution is
very natural and so like these types of
results you're gonna be able to get by
doing some kind of symbol yes yes they
do yeah I mean you may be able to write
so you can do certain things like for
instance if P if P and Q are both real
rooted then I can pick like the closed
upper half plane and then I can pick the
closed lower half plane and so it's
going to show that the roots of that
ative convolution are to be in both of
those so it implies that it in fact
preserves or of rootedness so that's one
thing you can do and I imagine there's
other things that you can do like this
but at least the sort of the base result
is is this and and it's like kind of
most general form they have to be sorry
and this is the the formulation that
Mohan gave in the previous talk which I
think he used the unitary group but I
I'm assuming maybe the real symmetric I
think orthogonal is is good enough but
there's actually a number of groups that
you can put there that you can
symmetrize over but it turns out that
this is equal to this expected
characteristic polynomial and as you
mentioned right by by sort of averaging
over the orthogonal group you're sort of
washing away the eigenvectors and you're
just leaving the eigenvalues and so it's
not too surprising that the thing you
get only depends on the eigen values of
the original matrices
and also there's kind of another
interesting way to write this which if
you if you don't have matrices well I
mean if you don't want to make matrices
if you just have the polynomials and you
want to know something in terms of roots
then this is another way you can write
it as well where I've sort of used the
shorthand notation lambda I means just
the I through to P lambda Sigma I means
the Sigma I through of Q they can be
sort of ordered in any order this is not
really quarter dependent least as stated
here but so that's another way to write
this so this is somehow at least natural
and in the way that can be formulated
there's a lot of nice ways you can write
it it has this really nice property and
we'll see that it also has a lot of
other nice really good nice properties
on the next slide so sort of the the
main thing that you can get from then
Walsh is result about circles is that
right once you have sort of real
rootedness preserving using that
argument i just gave about using half
planes you can then also do something
where you just sort of take the smallest
circle centered on the real line
containing all the roots and if you sum
those you're going to see that the the
max root of that of the convolution of
the two is going to be contained and
sort of the sums of the circles and so
it's going to be bounded by the sum of
the max roots of the two underlying
polynomials so there are a lot of ways
to prove this I think even you can maybe
just prove it straight from the from the
expected characteristic polynomial
formulation but you can also prove it
using that circular regions
so there's some other nice things I'll
just say it has a lot of nice algebraic
properties it's commutative which is not
obvious but if you just write down in
terms of a basis you can do it that way
there's also a way to write it a little
more symmetrically because you know if
you remember the way I wrote it have
that zero in one input in the Q input
and an X in the end the P input so it
looks maybe a little non symmetric but
there's a way to make that look more
symmetric you also have associativity
which is pretty straightforward you also
have a lot of invariance properties
which I have written them here but
probably the words are the better way to
think of them you can shift in any one
input and the shift pulls out or goes to
the other input you can take derivatives
and those pull out that's pretty
straightforward to see and you can also
see if you scale both inputs you can
sort of pull that scale out here up to a
factor and if you if you think about
maybe what this scale invariance means
there's another interpretation of this
that if you think of the convolution as
and I'll talk about this in a minute a
little more detail but if you think of
the convolution as being some if you
look at the input polynomials as being
polynomials in X and their roots so if
you just make the roots variables if you
make both input polynomials like that
you take this convolution and now you're
going to end up getting something that
is a polynomial in X where the roots of
it are somehow a function of the roots
of the two inputs okay this says
something like if you think of it in
this abstract way this convolution is is
like a homogeneous polynomial okay this
is maybe what this sort of says and I'm
gonna it's not very hard to see but I'll
write it down on the board here in a
minute
it actually turns out to be hyperbolic
when you do this and there's some
interesting things you can get from this
and then the last thing that's really
nice about it is it actually completely
characterizes which constant coefficient
differential operators preserve real
rootedness we've already seen that P and
Q are real rooted then so is the
convolution of P and Q and it turns out
that the polynomial X to the N is is the
identity for this convolution if one of
your inputs is X to the N you just get
out the other one so as soon as that's
the case any any q4 which convolution
bike
was gonna preserve real rootedness has
to be real rooted itself because it has
to map X to the end to something real
rooted so this ends up characterizing
differential operators which preserve
this property so again maybe maybe
another reason why we might look at
things in this form even though it seems
a little bit weird it's at first first
glance okay so you know we got this
trying on equality it gives us some root
bounds and you know maybe we're done
I mean maybe all the stuff that you know
like all these problems we want to solve
about Kevin Edison singer and all this
stuff I mean you know we just need to
bounce some root maybe this is enough
okay and and as you might guess you know
a result from 1922 is not enough to
prove these things so this this
unfortunately is is far too weak and
probably the moral reason why it's too
weak is the fact that the one of the
ways you can get this is based on
circular regions somehow the root bounds
are not a real stable or real rooted
polynomial fact it's based more on you
can enclose things in some circle in the
complex plane and even if I hadn't had
real rootedness like I could have
getting gotten some similar thing with
the triangle inequality I think you can
even bound the the modulus of the max
root by but like the modules of the max
root is going to be bounded by the sum
of the moduli of the of the roots of the
inputs so somehow this isn't about real
rootedness and because of that it can't
be it really about convexity or any of
these properties that come with
hyperbolic or real stable polynomials
and if you know the proof of Caterson
singer that MSS do that's a pretty
crucial feature and so it's not it's not
unexpected that this would not be enough
okay okay so the question of course then
is can we do better okay and the first
answer that is there are two possible
ways we could do this okay one of them
is well maybe if we knew more
information about not just the max root
or equivalently the min root maybe if we
knew more information about the interior
roots like the fifth root or something
like this then maybe inductively this
might help us to keep track more
information about where these roots are
and we could maybe use that to prove
some better bounds or something like
this okay that's that's maybe one idea
the other idea which is the one that MSS
take on in their proof
let's try to get some sharper balance on
the max root which ditch don't have this
property of being just generalizable to
basically any complex rooted polynomial
right can we take real real root earnest
more into account and the other thing
that I guess I should say I've kind of
gone on gone down this route of
univariate polynomials but I mean at the
end of the day we really care about
multivariate polynomials because right
we had some multivariate thing we do
some derivatives on it then we restrict
to univariate so really we care about
bounding the roots or whatever the you
know the the zero region of of a
multivariate polynomial and it turns out
and of course that's actually what we
want to do it turns out that some
univariate result in this category ends
up being enough to prove the MSS results
if you're familiar with the argument the
softmax and MSS is very much the first
like an item of the first kind isn't it
like it's like taking into account all
the other rules but I still see it as
and maybe I'm not thinking about what
you're talking about I would still see
it as something that is at the end of
the day attempting to bound the max root
maybe taking into account more roots of
course right that's how you're gonna get
sharper bounds here but at the end of
the day they're bound is still like on
the max root of something right so maybe
that's all I'm trying to say maybe we
can also get bounds on not just the max
root beyond just taking to account other
roots to get a merit bound on the max
rate maybe we can say something more
and then from multivariate like I said I
mean this was and this was kind of our
big goal right we we kind of studied all
the univariate stuff hoping that we
could then find a really good way to
generalize it to multivariate
polynomials which is what we really care
about and you can define a convolution
in a very similar way which I'll which
I'll show you get a triangle inequality
and it's too weak as it is in this case
and but when we get there I'll kind of
talk about what maybe what we can do
right okay what did we try what failed
what might still be true things like
this
okay so like I said the first kind of
bullet of that univariate part is
talking about roots that are not
necessarily the max root okay
and this is kind of like I said this
paper is sort of a collection of things
we found out along the way to failing to
prove something I would say and so these
are going to be kind of a handful of
interesting facts about this convolution
and conjectures that we kind of think if
we had a better handle on maybe we'd be
able to understand how we can improve
these bounds that FSSA it more so I'm
gonna kind of like I said I'll talk
about this I'll kind of talk about the
MSS result I'll move on to multivariate
and we'll kind of maybe you can see some
connections between so what we're gonna
do here is we're now going to have this
univariate polynomial it's going to be
real rooted unless I specify otherwise
everything's gonna be real rooted from
now on I'm gonna order the roots in
non-increasing order
counting multiplicities and I'm going to
define this sort of shorthand for
summing over some collection of the
ordered roots okay so if I wanted to sum
over the top three roots then my set I
would be one two three and I would use
lamb 2ip for that okay so the first
thing that you can get which has
actually turned out to be not very hard
once you know a lot of hard results is
that you get horns inequalities for this
and that basically means that if you
have some collection of indices that
work for all hermitian matrices then it
also works for this additive convolution
okay so if I mean there are a number of
these inequalities that you can get I
just add down some of the classic ones
so ones I'm most familiar with though
again there are many are first of all
well let me just in fact I think it's
written at the bottom of this I'll just
put this up there for yes yes that's
exactly I mean yeah you I think I mean I
think I don't know if you were the first
one to do it to basically get used to
get the root bounce for hyperbolic but
as soon as you have a private bollocks
I'll show I mean all you have to show is
that this is like a hyperbolic
polynomial and then you're done yeah
okay so some examples are this so for
instance one of them is just which I've
already written I equals J equals K
equals just the set consisting of the
number one so that's just the triangle
inequality okay but it turns out that
you can also do I equals J equals k
equals 1 up to some K
okay and if you're familiar with this
this this collection of inequalities is
equivalent to this major ization
relation okay which is usually written
like this and again I mean one of the
many equivalent definitions of major
ization is just that well it's usually
like if you have two real vectors a and
B we're going to use this notation a
sort of precedes B if sum I equals 1 to
K AI is less than or equal to sum I
equals 1 to K bi with quality
it's D and again the these are ordered
right so a1 means like the largest
element of a b-1 me is a large element
of B but you can see then how this is
exactly what you get in this situation
over here you have the roots of the
convolution and over here you sort of
have the ordered roots of each of the
polynomials some together so you get
some kind of major ization relation like
this it turns out and I'm not gonna be
able to talk about why you get this but
it's actually a corollary of this fact
and just a little bit of computation you
also get something of the form this if
lambda of P is major eyes by lambda of Q
so if the roots of P have this property
compared to the roots of Q then
you can actually convey our and it
preserves this property this is actually
a corollary of a result of porchetta and
bran den which you know many things are
in this field that were they basically
show that any linear operator preserving
row rootedness preserves this kind of
major ization property but you can also
get this from all this hyperbola city
stuff and let me just make a quick
comment about this hyperbola C and I and
I will sort of rush through the
definition a little bit if you're
familiar with it then you know you'll
know it if you're not then we can talk
about it after if you'd like but
basically the point is if you look at
the polynomial like I said so let's
write this polynomial P X comma a 1 D D
1 BD to be defined as basically this
okay so essentially I I write down the
roots as these variables that I'm
inputting and then I sort of take this
convolution just in terms of X okay and
so out of this I'm going to get some
degree D polynomial in X where the
coefficients depend on the AIS and the
BIS and if you remember from you
remember from this formulation this
actually demonstrates that the that this
will actually be a polynomial in all the
ai's X's and B's right this just says
you're looking at AI is is maybe the I
threw Tov P over here or sorry sorry bi
is the I threw dove P and AI is the I 3
of Q you're just going to do some sum
over some product of things like this
and you're going to get some polynomial
an X a I bi and the point is that at the
end of the day saying that this is so it
turns out that this is hyperbolic
with respect to the vector one and then
a bunch of zeros
and roughly speaking what this means is
right I mean or for those of you that
are familiar with hypervelocity this
follows essentially from the fact that
this preserves your over tunas okay
that's just basically what happens okay
I'm like I said I I'm just gonna leave
it at this if you're interested in what
this statement means and you don't know
about hypervelocity
you can ask the question at the end and
I can talk a little bit more about it
but for those of you that do know what
it means
this is then precisely what allows you
to get this fact because essentially the
way you should think about hyperbolic
polynomials is sort of generalizing the
relation of a matrix to its
characteristic polynomial to its
eigenvalues okay and so since we know
this about hermitian matrices there's a
way to transfer the this fact about
hermitian matrices the hyperbolic
polynomials and then once you know it
about hyperbolic polynomials you get it
for this particular hyperbolic
well definition that in depth theorem
when you use permutation when you had to
go through mutations in that in above
the definition of those permutation
polynomials at the interlacing : so I
think they're not yeah yeah I and I and
and this is like a this is a good
question to ask because if they were
this would be some really nice thing
that you could do but I'm pretty sure
like we have an example I Nick knows an
example I'd I don't know it off the top
of my head but you do get real rudeness
from them from this monotone permanent
okay okay I don't I don't think so
I don't think so no yeah like maybe
you've generated with swaps or something
yeah we tried with swaps I think even I
don't even think that worked so I don't
I don't think
okay so this is what we were able to get
it with interior routes you know once
you sort of see this this is not that
not a big deal I mean it just basically
follows as a core layer for some from a
big theorem but this along with this
extra fact is what sort of enabled us to
do the next thing which is to generalize
the MSS result about the max route to
something more general and Mohan even
touched on this already so let's just
move on to that okay so like I said we
were going to talk about what can we do
about interior routes maybe we can get
something better there and we were like
I said all this stuff is something
better it might have even been known I'm
not really sure I couldn't find it
explicitly stated anywhere but in any
case this is not hard to prove once you
sort of see the pieces the thing that
maybe is hard to prove even if you have
the pieces is is this and this is what
MSS sort of is at the heart of their
kind of barrier argument in determining
how far the barrier can move under
certain operations okay and the point is
this is some kind of like tweaked
triangle inequality okay so instead of
measuring the max rate of the
convolution of the two things you're
measuring some sort of like you know
perturbed maybe polynomial and then
you're sort of measuring the max root
there and the point is you get something
right if you maybe perturb in the right
way you can get something maybe a lot
stronger because this D alpha makes this
bound sort of a lot a lot stronger than
just the triangle inequality of course
right now you've got these you out
favors you alphas everywhere and we've
got to sort of figure out you know how
are we gonna deal with this what's what
you know we have some better bound but
maybe we can't really make use of it but
it turns out to be actually quite work
quite well and in fact I'll just I'll
just make a quick aside here about the
about this barrier method right the the
barrier method has to do with
trying to bound things of this form so
you're looking at something like D X P
over P and maybe you want to say that at
alpha it is make sure I do this right
you want to say that this is greater
than or equal to some yeah like 1 over
alpha let's say that okay
if you rewrite this what it ends up
being is just
or maybe it's the other way am i doing
this wrong anyway maybe it's uh yeah I
think it's actually this
all right this ends up and let's say
well let's say alpha is some input
that's sort of larger than all the roots
of the polynomial P so if you do if you
write down some form like this which is
some bound on this potential function
that they use for the barrier argument
if you rearrange it you just get that P
minus alpha DX P evaluated at a is
greater than or equal to zero okay so
some claim about the barrier function is
equivalent to saying something about you
alpha applied to P okay so that's sort
of how you can take statements like this
and convert them to say something about
the barrier so like I said once you have
something like this you get this tighter
root bound and the way you sort of make
this work is then you have this free
parameter alpha that you then can use to
maybe get some optimal bound for your
purposes the again reiterating this fact
with the triangle inequality you get
some sort of universal bound right if
you have some P that you care about and
you're applying some hitting it with
some Q as a differential operator you
sort of get the worst case bound right
you even get the worst case bound if Q
head had had complex roots and wasn't
actually a real stability preserver
you're getting this sort of worst case
bound on what happens here you have this
extra parameter that you can use to kind
of you know adjust to get just the right
bound you want given the Q you have okay
I'm not going to talk about exactly how
you might do that in practice but it
ends up being that this result is is
sort of I mean just from that and kind
of this conceptual argument I'm giving
ends up being an important way to
generalize the triangle inequality and
also it should be known that the proof
of this and the you know this type of
bound is very specific to real rooted
polynomials there's there's not really
anything you can do in terms of complex
roots that's anywhere near this okay so
it's somehow a more fully takes into
account the fact that we have all real
roots
the question then that's that's fairly
natural at this point if you know you're
looking to generalize this rather than
use it for some specific result is well
this is just another differential
operator we already said that that of
convolution you know characterizes such
operators and then particularly this is
a you know stability preserver so there
should be some convolution by some real
rated polynomial and again I think Mohan
mentioned this and it is so for some you
know for your degree D and your alpha
you can make this polynomial u sub alpha
with I'm gonna I'm gonna denote it as a
little U and if you write it like this
then then applying u alpha to a
polynomial is the same as hitting it you
know with this convolution okay and you
also notice that the max root of this
right the roots are D alpha and a bunch
of zeros okay so the max root is D alpha
and so you could rewrite this in a way
that looks a little nicer that D alpha
is sort of taken care of here and these
are all convolutions by u alpha okay and
then the next question is well why u
alpha and it turns out it's not
necessary so you can take any three real
rooted polynomials and you get a bound
like this now what's interesting about
this which I actually was just thinking
about this earlier today and I don't
know exactly what this means but right
if you take or that's not just one of
those u alphas you could similarly write
down a statement like this about what
this means it'll just be like you know
the operator will be something like 1
minus alpha DX minus something else DX
squared minus something else DX cubed
and basically you'll get a similar type
of barrier bound except the numerator
will be some weird differential operator
right it won't just be DX P I don't know
if there's any way to take make use of
that by like doing some really like you
know tedious calculations or picking
some really really nice
you know derivative that tells you some
special information or something like
this I don't know but but maybe maybe it
could do something I'm not really sure
though but I've just just an aside there
ok but in any case we get this and there
are a number of interpretations of this
one of them as Mohan
pointed out is just sub modularity okay
this is somehow right the traditional
sub modularity result that you would
write down as a function on on sets is
that something like if you have some
function on discrete sets you could call
it some modular if it has this property
okay so this is sort of emulating this
whenever you're looking at maybe finite
sets of polynomials and unioning them
you do by taking additive convolution
right so if your function was something
like you know lambda one additive
convolution over I of P I or something
like this and an asset of P is is your
input then maybe you would say something
like this is a sub modular function on
finite sets of three overrated
polynomials another way to interpret sub
modularity and these are all going to be
kind of ways to think about some
modularity is a sort of diminishing
returns property okay
now there's there's something kind of
conceptual that I'm just going to state
here but so a number of these properties
sort of suggest it may be majors ation
being one of them
the convolution has this feel of
spreading out roots right so we already
saw that X to the N is the identity and
so if you convolve with X to the N it
doesn't do anything
and somehow acts the ends roots are
packed together as much as they could be
they're all in one place as soon as you
start to spread out the roots of X to
the N and convolve by that it spreads
out the roots of roots of the output
more and more so you want to think of
convolving by a river rooted polynomial
again when the inputs real rooted as
spreading out the roots okay and so what
you can think then of this saying this
is just me rearranging this is that if
you start with some polynomial R and you
compare the difference in the Max route
between convolving with P and not okay
that's some quantity if instead before I
convolve by P I first convolve by Q so I
spread the roots out of are more then
somehow further convolving by P
or not the difference is less so somehow
the more spread out the roots are the
less convolving by a polynomial P
spreads the roots out further and this
again this is just if you're familiar
with some modularity this is just
another interpretation of it in general
but again this is maybe more intuition
for what what these what these operators
are doing the roots and in turn what all
differential operators are doing the
vertices just for the max right yes
that's correct
but to be fair I guess then right so you
get it for the max root by doing some
negations you get it for the min root so
it's really more like the bands art I
don't mean like somehow how clump
together they are I just mean like the
the minimum band that contains all the
roots something like this if you just
pick like the third root or something
like that you're not going to get this
type state
again this is just maybe me saying in
words what I just said about this
diminishing returns I I wanted to say it
multiple times because it took me a
while to really internalize what was
going on and even you know my my
long-winded
description maybe maybe I still have
some more you know learning to do but
anyway so these are a bunch of different
ways to say the same sort of thing okay
there's another way you can kind of
think about this which I'm not gonna say
much about it but when I was originally
looking around at properties like this I
sort of stumbled upon this like notion
of a poly major road which now is very
kind of around because of the relations
to completely well concave strongly well
concave Lorenzi and polynomials whatever
word you want to use and the way you can
see this is you you use this sort of
function but you restrict yourself to
polynomials whose roots sum to zero and
when you do this you you get not only
this property this sub modularity
property you also get that as the sets
increase so the sets of polynomials York
involving the max root increases and so
you need this extra like you know like
increasing property of this function and
then you get this sort of like I said
non discrete poly mate right so people
who are know of this sort of thing if
you're interested in this or have
comments or questions I would like to
talk about it I'm I I'm just sort of
saying this into the air in case people
find it interesting
okay
okay so okay so with that then we have a
bunch of conjectures which I'll quickly
state basically related to generalizing
this thing right here okay right we had
a triangle inequality we were able to
get horns inequalities now we have this
like better triangle inequality whatever
you want to whatever you want to call it
can we do something similar with horns
inequalities okay so if you have write
these I J and K which has this property
that all hermitian matrices have this
sort of triangle inequality for those
indices can you also get this okay and
the first thing I'll note about this is
the only thing that's sort of not
obvious to write down here is is whether
or not this should be I or something
different and in fact we have some maybe
more tedious conjectures about how
exactly what you can change this eye to
but if you think about this there's no
way that this one this one and this one
can be anything except something that
comes from a horns inequality because
what I could do is just let R be the
identity for the additive convolution
this becomes a zero the R goes away the
R goes away the R goes away and you're
just left with horns and equalities so
definitely the first and the last two
have to be something that comes from a
horns triple that second one I'm not
sure this is the conjecture we have we
tested it extensively you know as high
degree as we could and we couldn't find
a counter example but that said the
proof of the previous thing for the max
root is very dependent upon the fact
that we are only looking at the max root
and we have really no idea how to how to
generalize this I will make one comment
it probably can't follow from
hypervelocity okay or at least if it
does follow from hypervelocity it's some
special technique that I would I would
like to see basically because of this
problem so even the thing we know to be
true is not just as is true for matrices
and and again for hyperbolic polynomials
the intuition is you know if it's if
it's going to work through hyperbola
s'ti it better work for matrices and so
since this doesn't just as is work for
matrices
if hypervelocity is gonna help you it's
gonna have to be in some interesting way
maybe you know the fact that we have a
lot of symmetry here right somehow
I can I can permute all the A's or all
the B's and I and it doesn't change so
maybe some symmetry properties will help
you out I don't know I don't know but in
any case just a colander the quality did
you ever do this yeah can you put my
induction in the degree is my
differentiation there there is some
induction you can do and the original
proof of MSS does some induction where
they sort of take two roots and kind of
pinch them together and then and then
like induct I think on the multi
multiple like of the root there or
something like this and there is some
induction in the way you prove this
because I think for the base case you
get something really strong if say Q is
is degree one or something like this you
get you even get major ization it's
really easy to prove actually you get
just the full major ization and
equalities it's just then there is some
kind of induction after that but again
it like really heavily relies on the
fact that it's the mat like we were
looking at the fact that there's a place
in the polynomial where it's zero and
that that that's like crucial to the
rest of the proof so it is some
induction it's just in the induction
it's pretty crucial that we're looking
at one root
okay so I only have maybe a couple
minutes so I'll kind of talk about this
quickly it you know it's the least it's
the most unfortunate part of the talk
because it's the thing we really wanted
and it ended up being false but I guess
that's the way it is so I'll quickly
just mention this so this is what turns
out to be the natural multivariate
generalization I'll quickly tell you
what I mean by this so lambda here is
now in a vector of positive integers X
is a vector of variables okay and this
is somehow the degree vector for each
variable so we're looking at things that
are not like Co modernists or anything
like that they just have a max degree in
each variable okay and now instead of D
being the sort of convolution parameter
we have lambda which means now that I'm
going to sum over all possible
non-negative integer vectors that are in
between that are entry wise in between
zero and lambda and I'm gonna do those
derivatives on P so if it's you know if
it was 2 comma 1 comma 0 I would do 2 X
wonder there's 1 X 2 derivative no X 3
derivatives and then I'll just do the
rest of the derivatives on Q + 1 over
lambda factorial just a constant it
means 1 of a product of lambda I
factorial doesn't doesn't really matter
okay so this turns out to be the natural
generalization because basically you get
everything you want it preserves real
stability it characterizes differential
operators on multivariate polynomials
which preserve real stability and for a
very similar reason well it said sorry
real stability if you haven't seen it is
just non vanishing when inputs in the
upper half plane okay this is and for
very similar reasons to the to the other
case you get some kind of triangle
inequality which I'll talk about now so
and I maybe have like two minutes so
I'll quickly do this this is this idea
of points above the roots the point is
there aren't really roots of
multivariate polynomials so you need
instead you define kind of this convex
set that's larger than any real root and
you talk about set relations between
those those sets for different
polynomials okay and in particular you
get something like this which this you
know this inequality sort of the sign
goes the other way but this is
exactly what you'd expect in the
triangle inequality in the case of
univariate right this means that like
the interval from the max root of this
to infinity contains the sum of the
intervals from the max root of these to
infinity which means that the sum of the
matches of these has to be larger then
the Mac service
and we have this conjecture which I
think I I discussed with Mohan I I'm
actually a little bit confused now I
think we figured I think we all figured
it out but I think actually this
conjecture is still open but the problem
is it's not strong enough to prove the
bounds that we really want okay the
thing that we really want is it turns
out this which this is me just talking
about how this this kind of this is
basically me talking about how this is
equivalent okay and the point is you
want something a lot stronger and the
thing that makes this so much stronger
is you know barrier information in all
directions and then you want to be able
to move sort of in all directions
simultaneously this is the Hadamard
product of these vectors okay and sorry
I'm going pretty quick through this but
the point is this is this is very strong
to add in and if you had this it would
kind of give you everything you'd ever
want it okay it was it was perfect right
it didn't give any counter examples it
gave you just exactly what you would
want and it was if we you know this is
it
this is the thing this is what we're
gonna get but of course you know it's
it's wrong so we sort of at some point
we were like well do we keep kind of
hammering at this or do we just sort of
write down what we have and kind of move
on and we you know we hammer it at it
for a little while longer and and sort
of moved on but basically the idea is
you take something that's on the
boundary of real stable polynomials and
that can kind of you can use that to get
a counter example for this that said all
the polynomials we care about are
determinantal it's unclear if this
counter example is determinantal it's
unclear if it's still true it's still
false return mental and in fact most of
our testing was random and the best way
to randomly generate a real stable
polynomial is to take a determinant and
that was never false so it's possible
that maybe this is still true I but we
don't we don't know we don't know how to
go about that and then you can kind of
asked very similar questions in the
multivariate case which is a much more
open-ended thing and generally speaking
then this is just sort of a summary of
kind of what was left open after all
this stuff
that that is uh that is it
[Applause]
yeah horn and the quality you had one of
the many conjectures that was true when
like I equals J equals K equals 1
correct
is it true if I equals J equals K equals
you know an interval like like the major
ization type things unknown I mean all
of them are unknown except for the max
root it's just that you know we tested
him a bunch and couldn't find it a
counter example so even we hacked away
it equals 1 and 2 for awhile and that
didn't even work really so it's it
something new needs to happen if this is
gonna be perfect yeah there's only one
way to prove the original result that
we're aware of and it fair as John was
representing it verifies max root by
just testing 0s at one point for proving
zero at one point so it's really hard to
see how that method would give you any
information about sums of roots because
that's that's the way it verifies root
informations or a root position so
really I think fundamentally we needed a
new proof of the Year the original
result to get these seams but I think
that's the most interesting the sums the
Tucker's
[Applause]